I'm Michael Knowles with the daily wire
we are here for the Revolutionary
Communist Party rally we want to talk to
people figure out what the revolution
looks like the revolution will be
televised and we're covering this for
our YouTube channel the whole rally
today so I was wondering if you guys
could would you like to discuss the
revolution can anybody tell me what the
revolution will look like how we're just
interviewing people about the revolution
if anybody would like to give a comment
so we're doing an interview for our
would you like to answer any questions
what what is the revolution going to
look like what is going to happen after
the revolution this is a very quiet
revolution well the police is not to
serve and protect the people it is to
serve and protect the system that rules
over the people so you said your family
some of them are police officers they
said they want to abolish the police
knock down the police headquarters and
get rid of cops altogether I don't
believe in that it should be some type
of more an order well today we let the
world know we are declaring a political
war on their system a revolution between
Cuba and Venezuela we do not want
revolution
these people has to get out that flag is
what people see come along with drones
and bombs and troops fix with that flag
on their shoulder who come in to rape
the slaughter to plunder destroy and
dominate people all over the world that
flag flies over a hundred countries
where the US has 800 military bases all
around the world
these idiots wear their radicalism on
their sleeve but as I was listening to
them talk I realized I'd heard a lot of
what they were saying before you know a
lot of people want to say oh yes some of
the cops are corrupt something must have
went wrong along the way but let me tell
you sisters and brothers this was wrong
from day one I think apologizes is a
call to action on several levels I
didn't think that agency uniforms
you can ask me at all if we were problem
with this rising tide of Supremacy white
supremacy in America but we we just um
stop little children we go bomb houses
and buses of children we give tax breaks
to play chess but we don't just dirty
this country was founded on racism
persisted racism today the tools have
changed but black voters are still
deliberately cut out of the process this
country's been racist as long as it's
been a country
we're not gonna make America great again
it was never that great if they burning
the American flag and my people fought
for it
they're full of [ __ ] I found me a police
officers my family are American you know
from the Vietnam War to World War two so
you see they want a revolution over here
what America cannot happen
was it bad the wrong place this is the
only land of freedom this system cannot
be allowed to just contain the
revolution to those that this system
would just assume kill off anyway I came
here for the revolution and yet most of
the opinions that these guys were
talking about are held by mainstream
politicians candidates for president
so either the Revolutionary Communist
Party isn't all that revolutionary or
else mainstream Democrats are way more
radical than we had thought the United
States is running concentration camps on
our southern border
[Music]